hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Lauren God
and tonight we're gonna watch the
trailer for something that is on our
Facebook right now yay okay what's it
gonna be it's a surprise
what's it going to be it's a surprise
zombie accent what I was making but now
that I am
oh the equalizer oh what's that
it's a movie starring Denzel Washington
that's you ma'am and Denzel my man you
should do that voice all of that yeah
what's up Lauren you want to hang out
want to go do some now you wanna hit the
beach
wait the beach go lift some weights on
the beach wanna go play some volleyball
in the sand oh it's the this is the
internationally and this is the one
that's been approved for people all over
the world yeah we're like Filipino
Italian Chinese and Chinese Chinese just
mainly just Chinese aren't you and the
Chinese and a little bit of Chinese I
have a little bit of Chinese blood in me
yeah mm-hmm that's why we connect people
at Chinese blood feel that chemistry
that comes just from that blood erupting
from the groin area Chinese blood people
let's watch this trailer
cap sitting up straight like okay thanks
hugh jackman one soldiery to join the
others deciding Shani I live in a world
war night opposition oh good chloë grace
moretz think you could be anything you
want to be changing oh never bitch-slap
a hot fifteen-year-old more like 17 now
I like Denzel with the shaped hug
oh the guided trainee directed this
Sherlock Holmes yeah women stopwatch
nice not bad not bad
we why does he care about this chat -
for me tonight talk about the East Coast
you just I don't know when they send
goes something that's feasible when he
hardly knew I think think he just saw
her to get her ass kicked
oh so he's lying I did Julie kills you
and anyone you care about
madam if his skills possibly military
training
I want to know we really is always
working for Google I decided to come see
you three wait wait
he never want to [ __ ] with Denzel people
I'm a [ __ ]
brick by brick now my dollar buddy bye
bye
I promised that I wouldn't go back to
being actors
for you I'm gonna make an exception
haha yeah what a cool suite for somebody
else it should oh my
how's people that looks really cool that
movie looks like a movie that Tom Cruise
would have written to star in him a
little bit kind of does have that vibe
you know Denzel is a great actor but he
just like non-stop action films now like
a flight wasn't an action Oh excluding
flight but he just did like two guns
there was man on fire out of time Book
of Eli he's just doing what he wants
he's Denzel wash it I know he probably
has a lot of fun doing films like this
where he looks like a total badass that
was younger too right how old is he I
think he's in his 50s like mid 50s yeah
he looks great for is it yeah he looks
incredible he's a great actor - that
sucked Enzo's dick man
you sit over not everybody's Dick Allen
suck your boyfriend's dick good that's
my job what did you want to date look my
friend watches any of these I doubt he
does I don't think so I don't think he
supports your career when he watched the
first one I was in and then he stopped
caring it's like as I was hitting on you
the whole time and then you were like
I'm still gonna film with him we're
still gonna watch trailers together you
don't sound like a gay guy don't know
why did that boy okay yeah no you're
right about that Denzel actually doesn't
do actually recently at the same time it
does kind of feel like man on fire have
you seen that that was like him and
Dakota Fanning and then Dakota Fanning
gets kidnapped as a saver that's very
similar yeah it's a very similar plot
this looks better though than that I
like the idea that's Anton fook-la
directing it because he did training day
which was awesome and he also did the
replacement killers of chow yun-fat
this people is a definition of interest
right here when someone is intrigued
compelled you're gonna see this that's
the third time today that somebody has
pointed out my lack of injuries even
towards actions not one of your favorite
genres isn't I love action do you you
just kept thinking a Tom Cruise the
whole thing no but you know how Tom
Cruise loves to have make those movies
and star in them there is something very
masturbatory about all of his films
masturbatory really yes and that is a
word that has used to describe Tom
Cruise's films before not before me but
I think Tom Cruise and Denzel Washington
could totally do a masturbatory movie
yeah they'd be like riding over yeah
who's got the biggest dick yeah I think
dunzo he's black right away we know B
it's Denzel Washington a sister yeah
it's not racist when it's a compliment
you're Asian you're smart embrace it
no it's still racism even though it's a
compliment I'm Italian
which means I'm hung like a horse but
I'm also Filipino which means I have a
small penis which means I am right in
the medium the Chi girls out there when
a medium sets penis this guy is that no
one so anyway the equalizer I also don't
understand the title of the film why
it's called equally well it has to do
with time cuz time is the great
equalizer yeah I don't know why it's
called the equalizer don't worry I was
just [ __ ] with you just because he's
like oh I'm gonna time I'm gonna time
this fancy long it takes me I'm gonna
I'm gonna time this phone this is this
Oh doesn't
my name is Denzel Washington's I'm an
important actor you know to pump up this
shoutout we're gonna use some royalty
free music YouTube I'm just gonna choose
a random one that sounds good that one's
his ukulele roar edits he wants it wants
a shoutout for roared Rahr Rahr Rahr rah
rah edits so he said he wants a shout
out from behind the door or we're gonna
do this the way even though you can't
tell there's a core you're doing this
right away yes no we're doing wrong we
know that
like the mocker I'm just gonna play this
song for the for a [ __ ] time okay
we're coming Jesus born you see that
door okay we're going behind the [ __ ]
door for you and I was well worth it
Rory at its thank you
well buddy that was your shoutout
hopefully you enjoyed it Reese that's
fine 5 SS 95 UK subscriber think Sally
is cute UK man way to go
United Kingdom you won't be rocket out
there man yeah we're do what you do best
and keep recommending or fighting videos
for all you [ __ ] [ __ ] out
I just insulted Oh country robinette
that was not cool
Sally is cute but this isn't Sally this
is Lauren so when you put your name on
the shout out list they should have
thought this through now you make her
feel small and insignificant
my name is Lauren gah I am tiny side of
history this is not doing that was
Chinese accent oh my god I am going ahh
I'm gonna baby voice another Chinese
accent great smell gr8 T latina who
wants to shout out you guys
Sally is not here he wants a kiss from
Southie I'm sorry I got a Gorger who you
great Latino cuz you don't get a kiss
from salad or from Lawrence oh dude that
sucks
[ __ ] I would hate to hear those words I
hate them like every day but no dude now
you know what it feels like to be in my
position not something you can say
two days ago hey yeah I'm not gonna talk
about it okay he always asking pressures
on my boy very never - is Lily I'm a man
of mystery that's what oh yeah and if
you're new to the channel subscribe bad
stop [ __ ] you're buying three not lean
on me the botton you look like when a
guy actually my guy comes in your hand
and you're trying to get rid of it come
from your hand you should do it like
that I don't know what you're just like
flinging it everywhere no I can't see
like okay oh I did you wrong maybe no
that would only be hot if I hadn't come
already but that mean I come so we want
some other guys come on my head so
that'd be gross